What's the biggest mistake people need to avoid when getting into rank and run?
Uh, I would say launching too many sites at once, um, not being focused on a niche.
And even if you are focused on a niche, like I would not go out and just build.
I see people, I'm just going to build 50 sites, right?
It's like, for what, right?
Like you're gonna build 50 sites.
It's like, let's get your skill.
Again, it comes down to selling.
You could have 50 sites.
If you're not selling, you're not making money.
So there's people that have one site and they're making money off that side.
There's people that have 50 sites and they're not making anything because
all they think about is like, let me just launch a new site, launch a new site.
And I think you brought it up before.
You could be ranking on page one, false could be coming in,
but if you're not selling, you're not making any money.
So I think that's a big, big mistake.